hello I feel a little out of place
because systems architecture is where I
come from my talk is probably not going
to be strictly systems architecture so
excuse me up a stray off topic a little
bit and I send people ask questions here
is it sign specific talk you guys are
going to sit quietly for the whole time
either way I'll work with it I'm Quinn
Jacobson my PhDs electrical and
comparing everything Wisconsin I've had
a lot of fun over the years I did do I
believe the first soft core IP block for
an FPGA that was commercially released
back when I'll Tara was moving to the
Flex into the Flex family of products
what I'm probably my sort of what my
biggest accomplishment was I was the
chief architect ultrasparc 4 and 4 plus
at Sun Microsystems so I got to lead the
design for the move at Sun to multi-core
for the spark product line and so I
worked on very big computers we had some
rack mounted but that time we're so the
old you know you know servers in the
middle of the data center big standalone
computers i worked at intel for a while
then i went to nokia i want to nokia to
build a linux phone but no key decided
that symbian was such a great operating
system that why would they abandon it
and so what I did instead was this was
about time that GPS was becoming caught
with Sarty Mountain cell phones and so I
led an effort that did one of the first
crowdsource automatic apps it was really
fascinating it was a complete departure
for everything else I had done although
I did learn something really interesting
how small the world is so when the
topographer czar trying to figure out
how they're going to represent road
networks and how to navigate on them
they decided that instead of an
anything from scratch they could just
borrow so it turns out if you ever i
recommend go find a map database for
road networks open it up it's a netlist
what they do is they call highways or
high-level metal surface streets are
low-level metals they have vias it turns
out that all you're doing is rallying in
a netlist and so it's fascinating to
discover that I was really just going to
do optimizations on net lists again we
had a wonderful program we had one of
the first services that had traffic on
non highways we only had one small
problem and that was that the executives
wouldn't let us launch on either iOS or
Android and hence we were little less
than successful than some of our
competing platforms out there and then
about four years ago I left to start
vibrato technologies which is when we
talk about today and i was at nokia and
i was working on mobile devices and
there's really a fascinating transition
when you go to mobile devices you know
we went from personal computers to
portable computers and hunt really
changed when we went to mobile devices
because not only do we bring compute
with us but compute became aware of us
in a way that never was before and so
one of the cool things that happens here
is we have a device that only is
connected to the digital world but it's
aware of the physical world with lots of
sensors there's motion sensors there's
cameras all these sensors make this
device fundamentally different than our
interactions with it fundamentally
different but what I saw when I was at
nokia was there's some really cool
things you can do in terms of trying to
understand what a person is doing by
looking at the sensors on the phone and
we do this today anyone who's using
their health apps know that the phone
can sit in your pocket and determine how
many steps you probably took during the
day but if you're looking from a single
point source on the body you're going to
have to approximate the person as sort
of a perfect sphere sort of like you
know your classic
trota physics right we're going to model
the person as a perfect sphere and we'll
see how far how they're bouncing so we
took a step back and said what would we
like wearables to be not you know what
can we do with a phone or with a nap but
if we're going to start over what would
we really want from a wearable
technology because I feel it's
inevitable that we're going to have
networks of sensors in our clothing
sensors are cheap we're in our pocket
the logical next place for them to do is
to be integrated in toward into our
clothing so we looked out and said well
there's a lot you could do if you could
actually observe what someone is doing
at how they're doing it and actually get
a holistic picture there's this whole
range you open up everyone probably
remembers in the matrix when you know
Keanu Reeves gets karate downloaded
right ten seconds he plugs in now I know
karate we can't quite do that but if you
had a clothing that could watch how your
move and give you real-time feedback it
could teach you stuff much more
efficiently than you could learn it on
your own or watching a video or even
working with a coach so we can learn
motor skills more efficiently
effectively you can receive personalized
fitness to walk you through as we see an
aging population you know keeping fits
one thing keeping mobile as you get old
figuring out how to adapt your gate to
optimize all these opportunities here
for technology to really become much
more aware of us and help us be the best
that we can be with our physical
limitations and abilities of course you
get injured so then you've got physical
therapy to go through and then we have
this whole domain of occupational safety
where people are working lifting heavy
things there's no reason that
shouldn't have smart garments that can
detect that you're about to do something
really dumb and tell you to stop and
underlying this when we took a step back
and look to this problem we said the
whole key comes down to being able to
give to focus on the quality and not
just the quantity of motion it all comes
back to creating a feedback loop the
only way you affect someone's behavior
is through feedback and so what you want
is a system that in real time will
observe what you're doing will analyze
what you're doing and give you feedback
in the moment and that way you produce a
feedback loop that's very efficient and
that way you can help people and prove
what they're doing learn correctly and
avoid injuries so any questions or
comments it's a quiet crowd here if we
can do this as a huge opportunity out
there right if we can actually build
smart clothing that will be aware of us
and help us you know there's all the
sports domains fitness people are people
are spending huge amounts of money
really and efficiently we're paying to
go to a class we're in an hour in a
90-minute class the instructors may be
looking at us for three minutes to
evaluate our form the other 87 minutes
we're simply doing bad form with no
feedback on it or you know if you look
at senior health we spent 34 billion
dollars in this country on direct
medical costs from seniors falling we
spend tens of billions on physical
therapy and there is a massive shortage
of physical therapists because there's
more demand with an aging population and
our unhealthy lifestyles for physical
therapy then there are physical
therapists to serve that demand
and then if you look at workman's
Occupational Safety you know 50 billion
dollars spent on workers compensation
for workers injuring themselves on the
job some DVDs just civilians include the
military rehab for that is the 74 which
one the the that's just for ACL tears if
you look at physical therapy as a whole
in this country it's about a 27 billion
dollar and that's just a cost for that's
just for knees is 13 billion visit 27
would include me it's hard the VA is
really hard to get back numbers from so
it's probably larger and we do know
there's a shortage there we're actually
people would consume much more physical
therapy if it was available um and so
there's this huge thing and it's really
not that hard in physical therapy is
about observing on someone's moving
guiding them to do an exercise tracking
their range motion over time I mean
computers are really good at this this
is what we do we observe we analyze week
we can guide people swimming swimming
well we can i'll talk about specific
products but you know every sport has a
motion and what I want to talk and I'll
show you one of our products everyone's
always got their favorite sport right
and I like swimming something's much is
really a form centric sport I was a
swimmer that's what I lettered it in
high school and so yes I mean the
perfect example if you look watch them
on swim I have two teenage boys who both
competitively swim you know it's all
about form you have a lot of strength if
you don't get the proper form you don't
get the performance and there's really
no good way to do this I want to end up
doing is I lay in the bottom the pool
with a video camera and video the other
swimming above me and then I have to
swim decide the pool we look at the
video is really cumbersome same thing in
every sport I have people come up to me
like what about bowling what about
lacrosse what about golf
NS every sport has a set of skills all
we need to do is take the set of skills
map amount and then guide people do them
correctly the most requested feature not
be back by did stop by that's deposit
buzzies easier but the shock is highly
equipped it's like usually it takes
about when we're when we're talking to
customers it's usually about 30 seconds
in like well then can I shocked them
well there's a budget process be
afforded we avoid shock as a feedback
mechanism there's a lot of problems
there although if you only want to get
the extreme mender there's some really
interesting stuff is you look it to
estim to actually stimulate muscles so
take a step back if you really want to
get into it there's a huge opportunity
that someone will start to me afterwards
we talked about how as you watching
someone's motion a lot of people
struggle because they're not firing the
muscles in the correct sequence and one
of the things we have can potentially do
is as you doing emotion we can provide
very low eastham to help teach your body
which muscle they should be firing and
so the way estem works if you apply a
small current to a muscle it actually
will hurt slightly if you don't go with
it so if i want you to contract your
bicep i can actually send a small
current to it which will only tingle if
you don't flex it when I tell you to it
does actually ways that if you want to
look at it we can really take shocking
to a whole nother level but that's kind
of beyond the scope of this conversation
with actually a huge opportunity there
early wearables we have wearables
they're everywhere and they're not bad
there's just not that useful and let me
tell you why I think that is this is an
information gap so there's a lot of
information that we can get from a
device okay
and what are you doing how well you're
doing it what you do differently what
we're trying to build up to is what you
want as a person is some sort of
actionable insight what can I do
differently how can I live healthier how
can i swing my golf club better you know
it's all about what can I do to be
better how can I get over this injury
quicker how can I regain my mobility the
problem is that if we look at most
wearables today say a general fitness
band it's measuring it's a little bit of
information here now the information is
measuring does not have any actual
inside in it so will we have to close
that so we have the system and for
what's going on well that's very
error-prone if I have very little
information I'm trying to guess what
you're doing anyone who owns a fitness
tracker knows this there are some days
like you'll leave it on top of the
washing machine and suddenly you've done
30 mile done a marathon the other day
you wear it all day and somehow you
didn't do any steps so just there
inferring what's going on it sometimes
they get it wrong and so that how we
close that well we we infer error-prone
we get better the better the algorithms
the less errors it produces but then all
you can get to at some point that you're
still left to interpretation by the user
and so this puts a burden on the user I
give you a graph I give you some
information and then you have to figure
out how does that apply to me and make
my life better because only you only get
value from something when it can
actually change what you're going to do
information theory if I'm going to the
same thing that I haven't actually
gained any information from the system
now we can get slightly better if you
look at sort of state of the art and
some of these sports specific wearables
they do slightly better it's not because
they're actually any better it's just
because the universe is smaller around
them so if I know I'm on the end of your
golf club
then I know that you're probably not on
a bus or on a bicycle I know that you're
swinging and so it's not that these
wearables are any better it's simply
that they have reduced the universe to a
point that they have a better chance of
getting correctly what you're doing and
therefore the slightly smaller
information gap but what you'll still
see if you look out there today is that
all of the devices on the market today
still put a huge burden on the user the
information they're giving you is a
graph of data or some arbitrary
measurement of data that doesn't tell
you what to do differently it tells you
some metric of what you did you left the
plane of your swing by so many degrees
or you hit with so much speed well
that's interesting it's maybe a number
like even optimized for but it doesn't
tell me how to optimize for it so the
end of the day now I still don't know
what to do differently and then the only
thing I have left is trial and error so
with most of today's solutions all I'm
trying to do is they'll give me some
metric and then I'll just sort of try a
little bit of this a little bit that and
well that look a little bit better I get
a better number but what we need to do
if we're going to actually produce
wearables that people are going to love
and are going to change our lives is
fundamentally close this gap so that
with high confidence we can tell someone
an action of what to do differently in
their life and we can tell it in the way
that leaves very little burden on user
interpret and so basically want to
recreate if I defy had the world's best
coach or world's best personal trainer
or world's best physical therapist
staying next to me what would they tell
me and can we with a digital system give
you that same answer in which case and I
think we've provided a service that's
highly valuable and is really a game
changer
so how do we do that well we've got to
solve you know there's sort of the way I
broken you can slice any what you like
but the way I look at this is there's
three pieces of this we got to figure
out how to observe enough data so they
can really know you know what someone's
doing and that means that if you're
trying to diagnose even trying to help
some be a better runner being on their
wrist is not very useful yeah i can give
you roughly probably how many steps you
take because there is some repetitive
patterns in there but it's not really
going to help you be a better runner
once we get a lot more data we have to
be able to do much more accurate
analysis that data we have to think of
how to interpret that data in a way
that's very efficient and we got to make
that data easier for the user and one of
the really sort of interesting things
here if you go back to my information
gap here is the more data the system can
actually learn the simpler of command
that can give to the user because it
actually knows what's going on it puts
less burden on the user to interpret
understand so the more complete picture
that our technology can build from the
on what someone is doing the more we can
give them a simple actionable thing
where it doesn't take a lot of thinking
by the unused or to understand what
they're supposed to do they don't need
to be a domain expert themselves so
let's take these sort of one at a time
I'm an engineer what do you do you slice
the problem into pieces you solve them
one at a time the first how do you get
more data well more data to actually
really simple right if I want more data
I need more sensors now what we've been
working on is systems where we actually
build garments that have lots of sensors
in them sensors are cheap they're fairly
I mean thanks to the cell phone industry
MEMS sensors are really good and really
cheap so every one of our cell phones
has a little MEMS gyros mem
accelerometers
those components are wonderful now
there's some challenges if I'm going to
put a bunch of those into your clothing
I need to be able to synchronize them
this is actually quite a challenge
because a lot of what people have looked
at in terms of how they're going to
network together sensors on the body
don't take into account synchronization
real well even if I have the bandwidth
to move all the data from all the
sensors if I can't synchronize them in
time well if I know where one body part
is at time T t1 and where another body
part is at time t2 if our model a joint
in between how accurately I know that
joint angle is a function of how close I
know t1 vs T to it seems very simple but
if you look at what a lot of people are
doing in the wearable space they're
completely ignoring this another problem
is calibration across sensors mem
sensors are wonderful they're
surprisingly accurate for how small and
cheap and power-efficient they are but
they're not absolutely that accurate we
have a lot you know you have a strap
down gyro so inherently strapped down
gyros or have drift problems so we don't
you know when we build a little cell
phones if you look at the gyroscopes in
them you think of gyroscopes is you know
spinning things in a gimbal and they can
move around so you always know where one
direction is that's not how we actually
build them there are strapped down gyro
we know how fast you're rotating we
don't know where you absolutely are and
we just integrate how fast you rotate
over time which causes just compound
errors over time so we are calibrate
across them covering one sensor is hard
calibrate across lots of sensors is
harder especially if you look at sensors
if I'm a sensor I want to think of try
to keep your orientation in space if I'm
a sensor in terms of what if you think
of your airplane terminology my pitch is
well I can correct if my gyros go bad on
pitch real easily because I can always
look where gravity is gravity is always
there in the background I have an
accelerometer
I can see down so I can correct for
pitch I can correct for roll real well
for my gyros what I can't correct for is
yah so if the gyro drifts a little bit
to the left or a little bit to the right
I don't know that happened I have no way
to correct for that unless I get real
creative now if I'm one sensor and I
drift a little bit to the left a little
bit to the right it's okay but if I'm
modeling a joint I'm two sensors and
they drift independently suddenly have a
big of a compounding problem so we have
to solve the problem of how to calibrate
across sensor nodes you got of course
have enough bandwidth to talk to all
your sensors as in all of computer
architecture and computer systems
ultimately power is always going to be
your limiting factor some way or another
so if I put lots little sensors out
there someone I've got to get power to
them I either have to have a Power
Distribution where I run wires to your
clothing or I have to put lots of
distributed power and put a lots of
little power reservoirs out in the
system remortgages clogging spatial data
as opposed to say something like
physiological data temperature salt go
ad skin response which are sort of the
traditional we're looking at the harder
problem of biomechanical data of motion
there's lots we're we're going to
spatial data it all correlates right
because really we're trying bill
holistic model of the human and there's
a lot of really good work going on in
terms of how to do the other physiology
data we can talk about that if you want
but why mostly I talk about right now
will be the spatial motion data and if
you're if I lots of those sensors out
there in the world and you've ever been
to a computer architecture 101 class you
know you should program as a distributed
system just because you should and a
lots of efficiencies if you do it right
I'll put a little plug for a technology
here what do you look at wearables and
putting lots of wiring up humans you
spend a lot of time worried about wires
amazing cables you think that wire is
this must be a technology this you know
what can you do interesting wires
there's a company called Minnesota wire
they have a really cool wire it's called
I stretch they put an elastic core and
they coil the conductor down them what
it gives you is a wire that's extremely
flexible it stretches you can actually
stretch your cables and they have
basically infinite been cycle on them
because the geometry of that when you
bend a coil you don't actually put a
crink in any of the conductors you put
as a cable that has a infinite nearly
infinite been cycle I say nearly
infinite actually I've worked a lot with
these guys a number of years ago when
they first started making this for the
military they put the standard test in
where they're doing been cycle testing
two weeks ago they took down the machine
after some time after a few years and
millions of cycles because they couldn't
justify the lab space a more they had
zero breaks so they don't know they
don't know what the bed cycle of this
wire is but if you're in the space of
wires really fun wires play with size
comes in all that they make it and all
different all different conductors
gauges kinda to use so the time we're
using is very small we're using 32 gauge
conductors we don't need a lot they do
big conductors if you're going to lay
big cables down they can do big
conductors we're using really fine
conductors
the other thing you got to worry about
if you're trying to do try to model how
people are moving is actually building
clothing for people and honestly when I
started for brato almost four years ago
I was really worried about my
electronics I knew her some challenges
there but I thought they'd know what to
do and I kind of like well and we'll
have to build some clothing to put them
in turns out garments are actually
probably harder than electronics so
there's one thing to take away from this
I guess the thing is whatever you know
is you probably can solve this what you
don't know it's going to bite you
clothings hard we need the sensors to
move with the body if you're going to
model how people move and actually that
means the clothing have to fit well not
only that but clothing is actually not
designed to move with you it's actually
designed to shear so when because you
don't want to sort of restrict you so
actually you look at clothing in almost
all cases clothing is actually made to
not track how you move but actually give
you some degree of motion within the
clothing which then completely defeats
the purpose of trying to use clothing to
observe how your moving and people
really care what it looks like so you
can't just sort of you can strap bunch
of stuff but not if you want to i should
be able to use it in real world washing
cycles are brutal if you're Billy
electronics and although you can always
put they do not drag on do not dry on
the tag you can't guarantee people put
stuff in the dryer working with the
government industry is very hard it's
non industry that has really moved into
a first century at all and actually it's
a bureaucratic nightmare actually to
manufacture a garment legally in the
state of California you have to go
through a whole process to become a
licensed current manufacturer you're
going to produce one you're going to
sell one garment the California
technically you have to go through this
huge bureaucratic nightmare and so we
had to go become a licensed garment
manufacturer
it's a whole set of law just for gar
manufacturers it goes back I think to
the fact that gar manufacturers have
historically so violated worker rights
that you have to then go through this
whole process to verify that you're not
going to exploit workers even if you're
making extremely high-end garments
electronics and they still think you're
so you're saying that you need these
type of sensors physically that you need
to develop them or do you already have
these type of sensors is the technology
there or not yet that was one question
another one is that about California
there are some restrictions about that
hazardous material as is that all sir
concern in using a sensor but specific
internal in the clothing in California
no that hasn't care about the problem is
simply that California goes back to
really archaic rules when it comes to
garment manufacturing building the
sensors the sensors are not hard every
cell phone has a chip that's about 3
million millionaires by 3 millimeters
which gives you all the spatial data
you'll ever need and so if you're trying
to build motion capture systems we
actually have the building blocks quite
readily available fabrics and our
sensors like is the technology they're
like a reliable something that you can
use that has those properties level so
it's not if you try to look at and we
looked at this everyone's promised to
give me textiles with wires woven in
them and textiles with wires woven in
them have been you know ready next year
for like many other things next year
you'll have them and we've been told
that for ten years or more we know how
to put wires into textiles you can weave
wires into textiles doing that in a way
that can survive real-world wash cycles
and can deal with what we really need
wires to behave like is not practical so
we
gave up we spent a lot of time trying to
figure out how we were going to go get
textiles why is woven to them and said
well I'm just going to run a cable
because honestly I want to retire before
I'm going to get the garment industry to
give me a cloth I like it's coming
they're getting better I'm seeing some
of the well embedded conductors that are
showing some promise but no one's ready
for commercial production of textile
with embedded conductor moving on so
collecting data we know how to win it we
have the sensor the building blocks are
there we know how to build networks of
them we can put them into clothing we'd
with a data one of the things when we
look to this problem we focused on the
fact that we didn't want to take our
data and run pattern matching on it on
sensor data which is sort of the classic
way that most people address this
problem i have a bunch of sensors i have
some really good machine learning
algorithms i'll put the two together and
my job will be done what we found is
it's actually much more efficient and
much more powerful to take your sensor
data and turn into about mechanical
model so don't try to look at raw sensor
readings but take your sensor data and
modely human body you get all the
benefits of the fact that we know how
human bodies move there's a lot you can
do when you're trying to model a human
body that just reading looking at sensor
data throws away it also is very much
more robust if I'm trying to do pattern
matching I have to look at every
possible way I could swing a tennis
racket where I'm trying to build a model
based if I build a model of an arm
swinging I know the natural expected
variations in that and we can argue
about this but it's actually
substantially computationally more
efficient to model biomechanics that is
to scale pattern matching algorithms to
the scale you need to solve these
problems and the other really important
thing is as we're looking at systems by
running biomechanical models that are
human understandable we can produce user
experiences that are much more much more
useful and much more compelling for both
the end user and the domain expert and
so if you're trying to show someone what
their sensor data was when they did well
and they did it bad that's sort of
nonsense the average person but if you
build a biomechanical model you can say
you know get your arm up bring your
elbow in move your wrist this way it
produces a way to communicate to the
human to the people they understand
people understand stick figure models
they can manipulate stick figure models
an expert could take a six figure model
and says I want you to do this I want
you to take your arm and I want you to
swing it like this so whatever it is and
if you do you're like that you can say
you swing arm like this if I want you to
swing your arm like that and people
understand that and so building systems
that people can interact with and where
we can close the information gap to
provide people actual input it's really
important that we go our systems to
working about mechanical domain that
people understand I think I covered that
and the other important thing is making
providing feedback to people that's
useful so if you want to provide help
useful feedback to people we got to give
them information a way that that gives
feedback that's accurate timely and
meaningful so we have to give have to be
objective it has to be precise after
repeatable people have a very low
tolerance you ever tell them something
wrong they no longer trust you so you
have to always give them the right
answer has to be accurate you have to be
timely so if I go today what do you do
if you want to learn to do something
well there's always a videotape yourself
doing it and then review the video well
one no one actually goes
I can watch the video and two if you do
is too late you see what you did wrong
but now you no longer doing it so you
can't build muscle memory for the
correct way and it has to be easy to
understand easy to implement so it could
be something that I tell you it it's how
a person would tell you to do it so you
can interpret it so we spent a lot of
time working on on body feedback how do
we communicate to people how do we
convey information to them well if you
just hang good you just want to give
them some sort of nice regit or e tones
if you do it bad well if you can
actually write light up arrows on their
body in this case I want her to get her
elbow in that want her to get her hand
forward just draw an arrow on the human
body that's so many people to understand
look at your arm oh you want me like
this that's about a simple
straightforward as you can get we don't
want you interpretive we don't want to
try to give you some angles we want say
get your arm in so what have I been
doing we spent the past few years
developing assists modular software
architecture that does this and the
hardware we had to go the hardware of
course but the real interesting stuff
was the software algorithms to take any
biomechanical data interpret that data
and put into a model that is a stick
figure model where we actually can
overlay other data we can overlay muscle
data we can overlay other other
biometrical data and then building
algorithms that can very quickly run on
that model and give you instant feedback
on what to do how to behave and so we've
built we've built full bodysuits I can
do the you know stick figure moving but
those actually weren't very useful we
were looking for something a little bit
more scaled-down as our first product
so our first product actually is from
vibrato is a shooting sleeve for
basketball players so you slide on just
like a player would slide on any
compression shooting sleeve I have three
sensors here that our modeling that are
tracking my hand my forearm and my upper
arm in space so as I'm wearing this you
can they're the computer sees a little
stick figure arm moving in space so I
can dribble and I can pass and it's just
watching me and if I then go up to shoot
a basketball it will if I turn on the so
you can hear me if I go up to shoot a
basketball and my sure the mic will pick
this up if I shoot a basketball well I
shoot a basketball will give me positive
feedback I see some nice sparkling
lights I get because I get told great
jobs repeat that now if I break form and
I do a basketball shot is going to
recognize I bro form it's gave me a
feedback what to do differently so if I
shoot and say I don't snap my wrists
it's going to scold me it's going to
tell me to get my wrist snapped more my
elbow comes out common mistake players
make you'll get you'll see that I get
scolded I get told to bring my elbow in
if I shoot flat I get told to bring my
arm up we can go on and on and on
there's you know 50 some things it can
break down on my shot but fundamentally
what we're trying to do is take it and
give you a very simple immediately
actual feedback where I can prove my
form now you can say our basketball
player was fine what we're trying to
show is the building block of how that
can be applied then to any sport or to
physical therapy the same principles
apply
so let's see um a little bit more about
this you can see what we've done in our
implementation are nice stretchy wires
we did we spent a long time looking for
more graceful things we went with velcro
we have a garment has velcro on it we
have electronics they have velcro on
them you can make them and use them and
then you can throw this in the washing
machine and not throw this in the dryer
we have so this is something that's
being used actually we have customers in
the NBA n-c-double-a that are using this
I'm not allowed to one of the
frustrating things I have is that I
can't show you the data we've got some
really cool data that shows we actually
have one team where we've got about half
the players on the team chose to use it
this year but half the players didn't
and so the players that are using it
have seen their free-throws go up this
year compared to last year from six to
thirty three percent increase in the
free-throw percentage and the players
who chose to not use it have seen at
most a two percent improvement instant
bio feed instant feedback on form is
amazingly powerful we've seen players
who are veteran NBA players these are
people who shot I can't even count how
many shots a pie down their life and I
have a shooting coach it says I've been
working this guy for years I can't get
to change this form when you put sign on
their arm that gives them immediate
feedback like this and people naturally
when you hear a good tone you naturally
want to repeat if you're a bad tone you
naturally adjust we've got people who
are veteran players who in one hour will
actually make a very notable change in
the biomechanics
as much of a difference and we thought
about like they're going to be any rules
against it they're going to be cheating
to use this kind of product and
professional environment what is it to
help your practice we're not going to
let you use in the game probably that
one team has access to this product good
ones and abort it it's an excellent
question I don't know technology is
usually ahead of those issues I mean
traditionally today I would say no I
mean there's so many training aids that
teams use that it'd be hard to see that
being raised I could I mean in theory
yes I see your point but don't foresee
that being an issue question I think
almost every that could be generalize
right the question itself could be if
you're coming from a better country
you've got access to a whole lot of
infrastructure that you don't have your
another place so yeah having a better
coach having a better gym it's hard to
see that but this is great swing with
this thing on there without this thing
on a are they from different things like
practicing with this thing on me and I
want this I found a match so the one of
the key things we wanted we want a
product that would completely move with
you it doesn't in no way can strange
emotion so you'll see some people who
have trained age that actually like
mechanically try to keep make you do the
right thing we're not in any way
mechanically constraining you so if I
wear it I don't where there's a slight
different tactile feel simply the fact
that wearing two sleeve or not now a lot
of players were sleeves anyway and we
actually do provide them a game sleeve
that doesn't have the handpiece at the
exact same level compression so if they
want just to feel the same we can give
them a garment that feels the same but
in no way affects or actual mechanics
there may be a psychological aspect to
it and see the back ta somewhere through
the battery yes certainly that battery
doesn't
more than be there in the back way no
and so nor the electronics but the
electronics actually weigh about the
same as a garment there's no substantial
weight I mean you there you know a
little over an ounce of total weight you
look at that on a adults arm especially
when you talk about the bulk of the
weight is up here near the shoulder
there's negligible impact on the
mechanics anything possible that in fact
would be probably edited for the
performance because he no longer cares a
minor weight difference but a large
fraction is battery why is this big
thing here it's got really three pieces
at once a battery actually a non-trivial
part of this space is the speaker if you
don't have good audio engineers building
really small speakers don't work so you
just throw a big speaker at the problem
if I had a good speaker if I had a good
audio engineer i could probably get
about third this volume to go away one
of the remote speaker mo speaker I one
of the key things we did we built this
actually there is of course it has
bluetooth and it'll connect to your
phone I can then go and set what I want
my shot to be and all that once you
figure 4 player we didn't want when you
go to play basketball you don't have a
phone with you it doesn't make any sense
to carry your phone with you or set your
from the floor next to you speaker 00080
visual solo practice just by yourself in
the room like many players you could but
for practical standpoint it's a lot
easier just to make a standalone
solution in the back there per person
how to use it or was the sensitivities
biting I mean like
so when we do it is so if you're a
beginning player we have a portfolio of
shot types based on age and skill we can
give you a shot for more advanced
players I'm not going to go tell an NBA
all-star how to shoot a basketball so
what we do is we put in a value wait
mode we have them shoot and we have them
take 10 12 shots and will automatically
construct a model of their shot and then
if they like their shot all we're going
to try to do is get them to have ever
ever more consistency and repeating that
motion usually they'll actually go into
our app and you'll can drag let me see
if I can put this on the screen for you
guys one second and we'll try this
and the AV people are going to freak out
now that could be some preset security
than mine alone like I should go here i
just got it get this one try here there
we go next okay so when I should you can
see American real time I can shoot low
back at you hi I cashew the middle and I
can go to evaluate mode evaluate my shot
the cool thing is because when about
mechanical space I can have someone say
I can't get you to shoot the way I want
you to shoot again you should the best
you can and then I could if I was a
coach go well that's the best you can do
but I actually want your arm to be
higher or lower somewhere else so you
can go grab the stick figure models from
different perspectives and drag them
around and set the mechanics you want
even if I've never observed it so that's
one of the cool things about not pattern
matching but I'm a biomechanical model
is I can actually give you a target I've
never observed and of course you can get
all sorts of graphs and you can you know
tweak how you know good a player you are
all those things you can quickly
configure
and then lots of data if you thought
about providing a way to collect data on
whether you made a shot or not so that
you can later correlated with yet our
system actually supports if you have an
external device i'll tell you make sure
mrs. simplest being we actually can some
of our customers don't mind having
someone push the button but there are
some of the shooting we practice rate
itself a lot of people use the gun it's
a rebounding machine and those will
count make mrs. so if we have that input
stream we we actually can tag shots with
maker mrs. and we can give you a
breakdown of the difference between your
makes in your missus is the NBA so
looking prejudice as a kind of
collection on statistics like for
example people like some sort of
tracking device in there you could say
this player is it ain't six percentage
shots from the star court the heat map
of where they're making shots is being
done today by the NBA and that's a there
are a number of company to provide
solutions to map where shot or taken and
made during games they can't give you my
can't they can't really give you
mechanics of the shot right statistics
that it could it's actually an
interesting thing going forward is the
more you could bring more data during
the game day the more interesting you
can make the announcers position or even
if we can't let it play player wear it
during the game if the player would
share his mechanics then the announcers
have something more to talk about to
keep us entertained while the game is at
a slow spa and so it is an op there's
opportunity there to actually generate
just more data on a player which is
interesting so you can imagine how that
could be used in sort of by the color
commentators in a game or Zuri in the
future you could see real-time data in
terms of how players are doing during
the game
Providence if I put it in two senses the
mass number of parameters I'm showing
for right now we measure 50 some
different parameters of a shot actually
measure seven if you count the timing
sequencing events any any of those could
then can then be selected to be what a
player works on some players will go in
and I can go to those parameters I have
say arm height and i can say i don't
want that turn that off I don't want if
you don't want to look my arm high go to
something else on so we have found that
a player can't cognitively deal with
really more than three or four at a time
there's just for them and so actually
we're looking at going forward is more
auto selection where instead of us
having sort of a static set that you're
looking at at a given point in time how
do we have it that over time we suggest
okay you've got that nailed let's remove
that and substitute this more subtle
parameter metric in an overtime give you
ever more targeted metrics the problem
is that the cognitive load on the user
to understand oh there's something else
being measured not supposed to get
feedback on it it's quite challenging so
the limitation is how do you communicate
to the player this part of this book
this makes you fixed by you know the
player and some be also learning so
right now we do it by the player right
now a lot of our system is built on
explicitly either player or the players
are working with have really good
coaches and so it's really actually the
coach is usually we're doing it what
we're working on as are working with
these elite players is building the
learning so that then when we move to a
mass-market to a person who doesn't have
it that they're get the benefit of that
without needing that expert there and so
that we can then auto-suggest everything
and so that's what we're working on now
is taking the data on how elite players
and we've got we working with players
from NBA down to high school and even
middle school elementary players who are
some of the best understand how they're
shooting so we can then build a system
so that everyone can have the benefit of
a great coach you if they don't have one
and the cool thing about it is if you're
out with your kid your kid shooting the
driveway and he does something and you
don't know a thing about basketball you
can look at your phone and say bring
your elbow in and now you're actually
telling your son your kid your daughter
or something useful even if you don't
even know what it means how much does it
cost we don't it's not really it does
actually make sense because we actually
saw the service not as a product so to
our current users we're signing this as
a service that is part of a coaching
service so we actually work with coaches
and trainers and personal shot coaches
and so our current clientele is not
actually buying a thing they're paying
for a service of which this is helping
it be a better service in the end of the
day a consumer price point you're
looking at a couple hundred dollars
these sensors are off to show metals
kind of technology from selfness things
but how sophisticated early how many
degrees of freedom to be handling XYZ
surround her stealer xing li ye roozi
yeah we're using six we started out with
nine we started out with 63 access our
armor three axis gyro three access
magnetometer and throughout the
magnetometer because they're worthless
and figured out how to deal with yah
drift in other ways and relying on
magnetometer because
you know it what else they're planting
odometers just stay away from if you
ever use your cell phone you'll know it
doesn't really know what direction
you're facing until you actually move
something and to can't see that Oh
seriously standard commodity sixaxis
what kind of frequency range can you get
we can sample we run for a basketball
shot in one hundred fifty Hertz
integration rate as we look at some of
the other sports we have to crank that
up a little bit and the motions be the
motion what consented to the sensor for
the accelerometers can go up to about a
thousand Hertz which for most human
motion is ok there we are finding that
some human motion is too much for the
mem sensors look at a professional
picture the rates that they're moving a
professional picture actually no mem
sensor on the market today can handle
how about ski ski racing ski racing you
can do yeah full body to be great for
ski racers helping to keep their top
form not the ideal form for a shot
depends on how far you are from thank
you so do you also keep track of the
position on the court justice according
your yes so if I'm out practicing I can
hit up exercise it turned off you give
me one second we let players select
different shot profiles
OOP oh I don't have kak tebya so I can't
go to serve in Tehran we let you turn on
tues 3s so you can just tap the button
if you're going to go shoot a 20 shoot a
three or shoot a layup we have you if
you're using a rebounding machine that
actually tells us where is tossing the
ball we can our if you have other
sensors in the room we can use those to
auto select that for you I'm but is
important to the laser staying in one
place man most practice someone's
working on a shot type for a period of
time and they are different the
mechanics are there are slot
similarities but when you shoot a
three-pointer there are fundamentally
different mechanics interesting thing if
you look at it if you start looking at
biomechanic Steph Curry's got really
fascinating mechanics on a 3-pointer he
does it exactly the way they tell you
not to do it when you if you ever listen
to coaches always how you do your arm
the same you get the extra power from
your legs you'll hear that if you ever
hear a coach like about three-point
shooting Steph Curry does the exact him
out of leg force no matter where he
shoots on the court so special is not
always right he's not for super you
watch me or do you have one do too much
you can't buy flash chips with less than
a gigabyte of memory nowadays so and you
learn all those parameters that you say
that really the margin that you give up
my insignia was from the weekend we can
learn that we keep in learn without the
hoop because honestly the mechanics of
how you should do it is somewhat
orthogonal if you make or miss it we'd
rather have you messing with good
biomechanics and make it with bad form
if you especially look at youth youth
will spend a lot of time trying to make
a basket honestly if they're too weak
for the distance or throwing they're
actually going to read their actually
building really really really bad
biomechanics to get results they want
and so we're actually trying to scare
people away from that which one of the
reasons we don't highlight make sure
this is because honestly if you make or
miss it is important but honestly we'd
rather you had good mechanics we want to
make it so that people celebrate good
biomechanics not only good results
especially important for youth market
the types of sports did you go to
support yeah but not that allowed to
talk about we have out of we have other
products that were piloting both in
sports and in other areas you can
imagine what they are I mean well the
one of the piles we have is even leading
to anything a once you have a
biomechanical model every sport you know
every domain opens up so we've been
trying to work through which partners we
want to go with to produce solutions so
long term the data the checkup comfy
homes probably would be more valuable
than any of odd way that you have right
one of the cool things is that we're
building a huge database of how people
actually move it is really fascinating
which are looking at physical therapy
and honestly spin a time physical
therapy you realize that how little
quantitative data there is a physical
therapy it's like the black hole of
quantitative study you know they like
the yeah it looks good you know that's
good range of motion so one of the
things we're building is a very deep
database of biomechanics both healthy
and unhealthy human body soul would be
safe to assume that it will be a
subscription model as you expand your
business right yes the ideally the
hardware gets cheaper and cheaper
ideally we don't even make hardware I
don't want it the hardware is not the
interesting part is really the
algorithms and the data that's
interesting it's kind of like the
kindled analogy real valuable part of
the books the devices toilet so that's
why you hit it that's where we're headed
and we're making hardware as long as
until someone else can give me a data
stream that's good enough i will make
hardware the minute i can go take two or
three other people's hard wearables and
together to give me a good enough data
stream I will draw building my own
because it's a hassle to build hardware
it's fascinating I mean and as much
Glenn genere you kinda a little bit of
pride and they'll I built the circuit
board and I went and did the stupid FCC
certification process and I even pay my
text underwriter labs and yeah that's a
little bit of me as a hardware engineer
so I like that but honestly it's really
just a hassle that you try to get out of
as quick as you can in the business
world occasion for something to smoke
home yes we do any well safety
certification is fairly minor but we
figured in the domain of wearables
because it's on the human body even
though they do look at things like
stupidity walking stimulating gates very
big especially in the senior domain is
mobility it's definitely an interesting
area it's a real challenging one as I'm
asking predominantly because we know how
to we've been looking how to measure it
the problem is what is the how do you
get it on the body of your target
customer and the challenge is really in
how you get the sensors where you need
them on the body in a real-world
situation whereas if you look post-acute
care is much simpler if you somebody
went to rehab it's much easier than
trying to put it in a long-term case for
just a general population they can
imagine biomechanics that you going
through all the time and how you can
generate your database with respect to
healthy
new sport and it's clear that I can also
imagine escapologist trying to put your
sensors out our bony surfaces and things
versus soft body tissue parts that
you're doing right now you find many
professional people wanting even
something different than you do right
chemistry from okay I see the sensors
that you have on your arm right now yeah
somebody else being one of them on your
elbow and put money on responding sub
like that before on soft issue they move
around we do run around what we're
trying to do we're trying to look for
spots on the body where there is some is
trade-offs you hold tight right offs
between one actually where I'm placing
here is more optimal for viewing that is
for motion back now is fairly good I
don't have a lot of muscle that I put up
near the wrist with not a lot of muscle
back the hands fairly good I don't want
it on the risk because model in the rest
I want to do is actually see the motion
of the hand in space and the forearm and
space and then model the wrist but
that's a terrible place to put it but I
can see it really well so those are the
trade-offs that you deal with that's
just with the show / exactly so you're
not the only be worthless and sensors of
the pros we can and we also one of the
things we realize that no one ever puts
it on right so a lot of what we do
algorithmically is try deal with the
fact that every time you put it on it's
actually going to be slightly different
so a lot of our algorithms actually are
trying to deal with the fact that people
can't repeatedly put clothes on the same
way your sensors in there with respect
to those like where's your wife or where
the sensors are in this case they don't
need to be the same but in this case
they are so I need to put the velcro on
the person let's put upon me and he says
are really the best way to do it if you
only want to know if you can actually
just apply a small hey i do just peel
off adhesive and stick the sensors to
the human body that's the best way to do
it it solves a lot of our problems and
we are looking at solution that maybe
adhesive based
actual works real well piercings would
be another but that's hard piercing send
a move to Real no really just a little
bit of adhesive there are a lot of good
adhesive medical domain that will work
for us the problem it becomes then
battery life and some other issues when
you look at adhesive based but you can
look at post acute care actually putting
on a patient leaving them there first
it's three or four days you know for the
first two weeks of care so it actually
it's quite good to stick them on the
person kid you guys fill that down oh
yeah the jealous they use a really good
and those are all certified for medical
use so they're safe to use and so they
have really good materials good I think
we're since you're you're from Wisconsin
visiting Stanford one of the things you
should do before you go back like Mike
Flynn the computer architectures we're
all tell you to do this to go over the
red barn at Stanford we have state
monuments here to the first work I was
done by muybridge yeah actually let your
nose Ryan a badger I'm a badger part but
I do live actually in Harriet house okay
horse racing horse racing horses we've
actually is very fascinating
you